Сергій Петко близько 4-х років
легально пропрацював у Великобританії.
Будівельники заробляють у Лондоні більше 2500 євро.
Це дуже великі гроші для Молдови.
Однак Сергій був змушений повернутися на батьківщину
через пандемію коронавірусу.
Я повернувся, аби бути поряд з родиною.
Звичайно, з роботою стало погано,
а платити за оренду житла потрібно було багато.
Сергій із нетерпінням чекає, коли знову відкриють кордони,
аби разом з дружиною вирушити до Лондона.
Я хочу побудувати дім у рідному селі.
Працюючи тут, це неможливо. Тепер,
якщо до нового року я не повернусь до Великобританії,
мені анулюють дозвіл на проживання.
Однак значно складніше тим, у кого немає постійного місця роботи.
Таких трудових мігрантів, за підрахунками соціолога Василя Кантаржі,
понад 100 тисяч.
Якщо період соціального дистанціювання і карантину
протримається довго, то природно, що
ситуація небезпечна якимись соціальними потрясіннями.
Я маю на увазі зростання таких явищ,
як бандитизм, крадіжки і навіть бунти.
Інша проблема: молдовська економіка дуже залежить
від грошових переказів трудових мігрантів.
За різними оцінками, Молдова цьогоріч
недорахується 200 мільйонів доларів.
Щоб підтримати стабільність лея, Нацбанку Молдови
доведеться використовувати валютні резерви, кажуть експерти.
Нацбанк під тиском суспільства
буде в інтересах громадян робити вливання
з валютних резервів, аби лей знецінювався поступово,
у  нормальних параметрах,
а інфляції була на припустимому рівні.
При цьому трудових мігрантів радо зустріли
на батьківщині далеко не всі. Влада пригадала їм
жорстку критику на свою адресу,
пересічні громадяни - про несплату податків.
Від початку місяця тих, хто в'їжджає в країну,
зобов'язали придбавати медичну страховку за ціною 100 євро.
Ви знаєте, скільки коштує страховка
в Німеччині, Великобританії, Італії?
У Молдові медична страховка забезпечує безкоштовне лікування.
Ті, у кого немає медичного полісу, у разі госпіталізації
заплатять принаймні за 7 днів перебування в лікарні.
І хоча продажі медичних страховок збільшились
у 7 разів за останні два тижні, багато хто з заробітчан,
у тому числі й Сергій Петко, вважають їх абсолютно непотрібними.
Усе одно, мовляв, за послуги лікарів доведеться платити.